bonsoir galles merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france avez vous d'autres
précisions on sait qu'on est à la veille
de la toussaint
pas de lien pas de piste en tout cas
privilégier pour un choix c'est la
police judiciaire qui a été saisie
effectivement la police judiciaire a été
saisie le maire de lyon vient tout juste
de se présenter devant la presse
c'était il ya cinq minutes à peine et
nous a simplement dit que pour l'instant
aucune piste n'était privilégiée pas
d'information ont véritablement donné à
part le maire de lyon ce que j'ai pu
savoir moi c'est que bien j'ai discuté
avec notamment un témoin un habitant du
quartier qui me disait tout à l'heure
qu'il avait entendu effectivement tout
détonations elysées j'ai tout de suite
compris que ce n'était pas simplement
des pétards j'ai tout de suite compris
que c'était quelque chose de grave qui
arrivent et surtout dans ce quartier
très calme habituellement
imaginez bien que deux coups de feu
comme ça et bien ont affolé tout de
suite le quartier des gens qui étaient
aux alentours se sent bien courir très
rapidement et si l'allemande honte vous
le disiez le prêtre a ensuite été emmené
à l'hôpital dans un état
évidemment et c'est lorsqu'il a fermé
son église que il a été visé par par cet
homme
exactement j'ai pu également croiser une
personne de la communauté orthodoxe qui
le disaient qu'ils en tout cas à sa
connaissance il n'y avait pas d'office
après juste cet après midi et que
effectivement il était simplement se
prête en train de fermer l'église au
moment où il a été attaqué donc sachant
qu'il est là et votre invité tout à
l'heure le disait effectivement depuis
quelques semaines un seulement parce
qu'il ya avant il y avait un prêtre qui
était présent depuis 2012 dans cette
église il ya quelques semaines il est
parti et donc les remplacer à part celui
qui a été attaquée tout à l'heure aux
alentours de 16h30 à lyon on le voit sur
ces images en direct gaëlle berger le
quartier est complètement bouclé les
militaires sont sur place oui
effectivement moi je suis arrivé il ya
déjà une heure et demie mais met tout de
suite les les pompiers la police la
police municipale la police nationale
sont arrivés très vite sur place pour
boucler immédiatement le quartier alors
vrai qu'un précisé que selon des
informations de notre média radio scoop
sur radio scoop points comme et
on n'a aucune information un suspect a
été interpellé alors ça ces sources
policières qui nous la quittons
d'ahuntsic et on ne peut pas dire
évidemment que c'est de l'auteur des
coups de feu bien évidemment pour
l'instant à ce stade on peut pas le
conserver a d'autant qu'il a été
interpellé dans un kebab du 3e
arrondissement de lyon et pio il n'était
pas en possession d'armes à feu alors
est ce que c'est bien l'auteur des de la
fusillade mais qui a eu le temps de se
débarrasser de l'arbre est ce que il n'a
finalement rien à voir avec cette fille
est évidemment on sera relativement vu
qu'il est en tout cas un suspect a été
interpellé a été interpellé merci
beaucoup
gaëlle berger pour cette information on
va suivre évidemment à l'évolution de
cette traque justement à celui qui a
tiré sur ce prêtre orthodoxe aux
alentours de 16h dans ce quartier de
lyon merci beaucoup pour ces précisions